Hi, I'm Steve Hassenplug and this is Monster Chess.
It's a very large Lego chess set.
It took four of us about a year to design and build.
There's about a hundred thousand LEGO pieces...
...and it's about $30,000 worth of Lego.
If you look at it, you can see all the pieces are of different heights.
So, like the more important pieces are the bigger heights,...
...which is the way it really is in chess.
The higher-ranking pieces will actually have actions that they can do...
...like the knight, whenever it's moving, it actually runs its legs...
...so you can see the legs moving.
The rook actually has a cannon that'll fire when it puts a king in check.
The queen and king both have a scepter that they rap...
...and then the bishop has a candle.
And the pawns are just pawns, they don't really do anything.